Well,
I always stay away from,
I live in a place which has been cursed
with interference by,
by olders,
we,
the party that I represent a keep to a
very,
very rigidly neutral lane,
whatever,
people to hear a decide in terms of who
your president does,
who your congress members is,
what your government does as a modern
tardy for people who live here.
From an artist perspective,
of course we're entitled to say we want
to Ireland to be part of that.
And given that 46 million or so people
here have their roots in Ireland,
we think that should be a,
an issue.
And you know,
at some moral at arden does partitioned,
it's,
that's another gentleman and coercion
into our affairs at con be stripped and
dogs.
And I'm quite sure that if a future
administration decided it was setting
that strategic interest to incorporate
the British government to create
conditions for our issue them to the
dump would hop.
And so without getting involved in any
of the other,
uh,
issues,
I certainly would,
would argue that it should be a martyr.
And incidentally,
it is the most successful foreign policy
position,
uh,
at this time.
I mean,
the red is based process in many ways.
A held in its infancy by President
Clinton continues to be helped by the
Bush administration.
It's,
it's,
it's the success that has worked and it
would not have worked except for Irish
America and for the people who live here
in the U.
S.